writing Japanese is hard I know what
you're thinking da Josh it's Japan when
they go in they go all in but it's worse
than you think
it's ridiculously ridiculously hard
growing up I was a language nun look at
me making this video guess I still AM
through the years I spent time learning
this script and these scripts and these
ones as some time learning this and even
more with all right you get it and then
I went for Japanese see in the u.s.
there's this flu that goes around it's
called Japan affiliate catch it and
you're off reading manga watching anime
and eating the kind of sushi with the
fish that's all in the top like I was
committed though I headed for the
library and straight to the Japanese
books this was back when the new library
was being built so they were holding
books hostage in this dingy place with
no a/c the books are all shuffled around
down on these low shelves you know the
ones that are like below your knee level
on the ground so I do my engine band and
I scan the area for resources fluffy
book about Japanese is for everybody
Pass easy Japanese in five seconds a day
pass cartoon cat yay by the way you
learn some Japanese I promise double
pass but then there it was the biggest
the heaviest the densest text book in
the entire section modern Japanese book
1 grammar lessons he called my name it
said he came out Scholl so I rush home I
bust open the book and it hits me with
syllables my first thoughts are well the
optimist in me comes out and says no
these look so fun and japanesey
but guess what the pessimist in me said
that's like 76 more symbols than I want
to memorize the pessimist inside me is
an Oni who's that fast counter the
optimist won out and for good reason it
was actually less of a hassle than it
looked like at first just 46 characters
in total on account of some of the
syllables turned out to be duplicates
with too little voicing slashes added to
their heads even better I was told this
is technically all I needed to know to
write every Japanese sound that's all
the syllables the language has thanks to
Japanese being all neat and orderly in
the way it lays out syllables and that's
great until I find out that the friendly
syllables are lies like when the T plus
e syllable is actually Chi and then the
T plus U syllable is su or when this
this and this actually sound like that
that and that the more I read the more
Japanese was saying but wait there's
more more compound syllables more double
consonants more historical syllables
they were hiding from me and just forgot
to mention asterisk mark all over the
place but hey historical spelling and
complicated workarounds I come from
English baby and that's how we write
plus I just did a whole rant on Tibetan
so I can handle some clunky syllables
besides compared to our Japanese
syllables used to be written it's all
super regular so that's a relief
without giving them time to breathe they
tell me that for each one of these
syllables I'm actually going to have to
learn two characters yes Japanese has
two syllabaries the one I spent hours
sweating over was still oh no no these
are the same syllables written in
katakana so our hiragana and katakana
for writing different sounds nope the
syllabaries don't do anything different
then when do I use this one or that one
oh just keep in mind that they use four
different syllables in different
contexts Japanese is very context
sensitive after all smile but none of
that is what makes Japanese tough it's
when they introduced yet another mixed
in script that things start getting
serious
I mean seriously seriously roll the
clocks back to the day Japan learned to
write they learned it from China and
learning to write from China meant
memorizing thousands of characters just
to read the basics
yeah well unlike other places that learn
their penmanship skills from that
formidable cultural powerhouse that was
the Middle Kingdom Japan held on to its
long master list of Chinese characters
oh they held on to it real tight they're
called
kanji and they're the backbone of
Japanese even though syllabaries I was
learning came from simplified versions
of some of these characters at first
they passed this kanji stuff off as a
third native system you know you got
your hiragana your katakana your kanji
and instead of different characters for
different syllables these are just
different characters for different words
you know like how you learn to say new
vocabulary when you're
other languages with kanji you get to
learn to draw your new vocabulary to so
exciting that's when I learned about a
dictionary with more than 50,000
characters to play with that's a lot of
characters I think it was maybe more of
a mind game to make me okay with what
came next don't worry I was told you
could do all right reading basic
Japanese if you just learned a couple
thousand characters oh-oh-oh just a
couple thousand I guess I was supposed
to say Oh fifty thousands a lot in that
case two thousand should be a walk in
the Zen garden are you not supposed to
walk in those a comb through the Zen
garden maybe they even downgraded me
again telling me I could pat myself on
the back for just mastering the basics
if I made it through the first a
thousand and six characters a thousand
and six yeah this was slow it was
time-consuming
they started me with these simple
real-world examples like trees suns and
moons and they looked off but if you
squint your eyes you could see it but it
was more trickery after a couple hundred
it started to be really clear that most
kanji aren't drawings of the words I was
learning at all
no way it took me a while but I figured
out what was going on there like playing
charades with somebody who has a very
specific word in mind but refuses to
give you any good hints and the clues
you do get are like way out of date like
one word something to do with trees okay
sounds like or got it nobody nobody oh
I'm sorry
the answer was table see the thing he
missed was that or sounds like bored
which is an old word for table obviously
yeah most kanji are this kind of strange
combination of a sounds like piece with
something to do with piece except that
the sounds like might not sound like the
thing it's supposed to sound like and
the something to do with gonna have
absolutely nothing logically to do with
what the character means it's no good
waving these complexities aside by
saying that well it's a lot to learn but
at least you're fundamentally just
learning a character for each basic word
for one a single character might mean a
bunch of different things when it combos
with other characters it can even mean a
bunch of different things on its own
even worse for beginners though there's
more than one way to pronounce almost
every single one of these characters
Japanese is very contact sensitive after
all wink smile and that is the problem
with kanji they aren't just kanji there
are a bunch of problems all mixed
together it's the most bizarrely
complicated writing system within a
system ever devised by humankind and
next time I'll show you exactly what it
was about kanji that really pushed me
over the edge I like having you here
spending some time with me thinking
about the world's toughest writing
system stick around and subscribe for
language